n Cal how's the family Felix got into
medical school you're paying of course
of course well I know our pockets aren't
as deep as yours hopefully you'll play
nice in the bidding war today oh Cal I
don't want to start a war with you we're
not interested in a bidding war we've
set the price either you can pay it or
you can't what Claire means to say is
this technology is not exclusive
everything you see today will be
available for your organization with top
of the line security to ensure that your
data stays secure remotely accessible
and permanently backed up on a private
apocalypse proof server at one of our
bases in North Dakota or Alaska
Alaska isolated and cold easier and
cheaper to maintain security and
temperature control of the servers I
assume you're underground and using
geothermal cooling that's correct Miss
Sova Nat
please Cal wants us to update all three
systems on his watch why someone said
the color cycling made him look like a
disco ball was it Vic or Natalia does it
matter yes because if this is about
function or ego I have different
solutions function he doesn't need help
with ego we can have all three
accessible through a single interface
but it could create security issues a
back door into the systems that would
make it much easier to hack as long as
you have legitimate access to one of the
systems you could get into the other two
is that a bug or a feature depends on
how clandestine and classified you want
your organization to actually be in
practice the watches are a nerd until
Isaac is activated right more or less
until you're activated and we maintain
activation it's just a watch a very
Smart Watch yeah but without activation
and the brick it's just a watch that
someday May alert you to get off your
ass and get to work so until activation
there really isn't a threat not to
security but they are passive they are
recording everything all the time and
filling the databases if he wants his
analyst to be able to access all that
Intel and data then feeding all three
into the same repository could be
beneficial but it's definitely not
secure and what about the other
databases like diamond yeah I mean sure
it's all built on the same Tech if he
wanted a back door into their operations
to monitor them it's just a matter of
giving him access to their database how
hard would that be to hook up it's one
server and one update 5 minutes but it
would put our other contracts in danger
if they ever found out how would they
find out the same way Cal would find out
they would all have access to the same
back door if they are all from the same
roof it's just a matter of finding the
right file it's all there but if someone
gets bored or goes looking they can find
anything they want if they've got the
skills and patience to weed through the
garbage
first I'd really like to see the new
prototypes when you have them ready
until then it's a pass for me that's too
bad Nat I really think you'd benefit
from getting in on this early be able to
shape the R&D she's right it's not a
good fit
besides I'm not really comfortable
working with private organizations with
practically no public profile Beyond
soal love concern I can't imagine your
entire business is built around tactical
knee pads I value discretion Mrs
Ortiz and I am sure you can appreciate
that it's not wise for a woman in this
industry to lay all her cards on the
table until she is ready to play them I
can if you're concerned about the data
we can build a private server with
biometric security
only people you've personally vetted
would have clearance to access or amend
your services that's excellent to know
Alexander please do get in touch for a
demonstration once you get the interface
down to a single component the Prototype
should be ready in a couple of months
excellent well I'll let you finalize
this deal Cal see you the benefit later
wouldn't miss it for the world now Alex
tell me where do I
sign if you mobile shade server Works
half as well in the field as it does in
the simulation this could be a game Cher
we're glad you agree does Net know about
this no this is a fail safe for your
agents only good good there may come a
time when you need to cut off her access
to the network and until you can isolate
your access this is an insurance policy
against a potential coup you're a true
patriot I wouldn't say that I'm sure Nat
would be willing to pay top dollar for
something like this I'm sure she would
but some things are too dangerous to
give to the highest bidder some things
should only belong to the
people now I have big plans for this
system of yours that's excellent Cal if
I wanted to utilize your system for
three organizations would I need to wear
three of those watches in three of those
bricks or could you put all three on a
single unit for me I'm not sure what you
mean
I'm looking at your technology and I see
other organizations who could benefit
from these tools the NSA is just the tip
of the iceberg when it comes to
intelligence and security I have other
more obscure teams at my disposal who
could utilize this technology it would
increase my order tfold and give you and
the MS plenty of seed money to play
around with more private contractors not
at all Homeland Security strict L
Homeland and governmental entities and
they all fall under your purview of
course I am the secretary if you're
looking for a more discreet single unit
we could house all three on a single
system and you decide which system you
want to access through the interface can
you get rid of the brick for me for just
you or for you and all the field agents
just me I think it's helpful to have the
identification on the back the risk can
be a little hard to see but that Beacon
of Hope in the dark illuminating your
face there's something heroic about
[Laughter]
that hostile detected hostile eliminated
hostile detected hostile eliminated what
do you think I think this is a waste of
time it's just for the field test I
promise if the results come back and
they prefer and uh we can delete Isaac
if we were just going to delete it all I
don't see the point in wasting time
building an entirely separate AI we
could be investing this time in refining
Anna instead of building a Superfluous
backup they've requested a more
impersonal AI for the field test did
they request it or did you ask them to
request it you know how they are fine
but Isaac is not going to be as smart or
independent as Anna I don't have time to
do all that reprogramming in recording
he will have to be very binary in his
morality if you're fine with an AI that
doesn't get Nuance I'll add him as an
option I think the users will feel more
comfortable with a less humans sounding
AI Anna can be a little much you're a
little much I don't like how human she
is sometimes hostile detected
recommendation eliminate or sedate she's
hilarious and she gives you choices
you're telling me you would rather have
direct order ERS from an AI than
operational Choice I'm telling you I
don't think people are ready for an AI
that can pass the touring
test sir I wanted to follow up about
that professor in New York what
Professor Amherst his student was trying
to seduce him so did he sleep with her
no sir so your update is there is no
update not exactly I don't care about
some college professor is there a
problem with the Isaac system no the are
still coming in there's still too much
data to sore through but I think we
might want to take a closer look at this
professor is he sleeping with a
different student no sir he's been
giving lectures about viruses resetting
the world to curb climate change so C or
dangerous expert in virology who could
help nature
along honest opinion Maas it's ambitious
the surveillance technology and
capabilities are a clear Advantage for
both the NSA and and the Black Tusk any
downsides honestly I don't know how
secure their network is it would be very
easy for them to cut corners and have
everything funnel into a central
repository without doing an on-site
appraisal of their servers and security
I would expect other users on the same
network could access your comms and
Intel that's very helpful I aim to
please we should speak more after this
personal or professional profession
what's your favorite geometric shape a
diamond interesting you know you can
tell a lot about a person by their
favorite shape what's yours technically
it's a plain curve
Parabola yeah that's you're not what I
expected Mr
OVA why would I want that if they can
walk on two legs instead of four they
could be more agile and fit through
tighter spaces sure I can see a use case
for that so we're approved how much is
this going to cost me not much we could
even tack this onto the R&D budget
you've already approved Claire's really
excited about the
prospects so this is to make your wife
happy you know what they say happy wife
happy life no one who is really happy
says
that
I see the value for Cal and his teams
but I don't really see the value in an
AI Handler for my organization if your
operatives are left alone in the field
my operatives would never be left alone
in the field in a perfect world yes but
we do not live in a perfect world go on
if an operative is alone in the field
our AI can take over robotics automation
to maintain perimeter defenses and the
likelihood of a friendly fire casualties
next to zero how does the AI detect
friendlies Biometrics and personalized
ID the watches and the bricks they're a
bit bulky any chance of miniaturization
or combining both the receiver and the
interface none this generation we are
working on combining the two pieces into
a single unit but it would require a
larger interface to house both
components and will be exponentially
more expensive expense is not an issue
for me I think we'll stick with the more
cost effective and tested methods
watches and
Bricks I'd like you to meet Natalia Sova
nice to meet you Miss sokova Cal says he
wants us to work together I think he's
just trying to use my budget to expand
his little experiment is your
organization using the Ortiz robotics
Tech yes you're not worried about the
potential security breaches with Isaac
yes we are not using Isaac we're using
the system agnostic from the AI are you
sure that's what Alex told me did Clare
confirm it no if you don't mind I'd like
to do a security protocols check on your
version of their systems I believe they
may be a major exploit that could be a
matter of National Security well I don't
belong to any one nation my Enterprise
is global then there is a potential
exploit to your Global Security
everything is locked on a biometric
server if you can access my system I may
have a job for you or I may need to
re-evaluate whether or not to eliminate
Alex from my future
endeavors I hope you understand that
you're not interested in renewing my
contract
sure I understand and that all the
design work that you have created during
your tenure here is now property of
Ortiz robotics you own everything you
don't want that sucks and is
broken goodie for you we own all of the
designs so if elements of of your
designs are repurposed and used in any
other application you have no
intellectual property ownership or claim
to any designs that you have worked on
during your time at Ortiz robotics okay
this is not exclusive to designs you've
submitted for review this includes
designs that you've developed in the
last 6 months on any Ortiz robotics
equipment or on its properties what do
you mean it's properties since you were
living in corporate housing anything you
created in the apartment is also
property of War's Robotics are you
[__] kidding me well I wish I was you
really should have read your contract
thoroughly before signing it if you have
an issue with this you could avoided the
clause in section 9 or found off campus
housing with what you pay me off-campus
would have meant West Virginia we wish
you great luck in the future and look
forward to seeing what you do next thank
you for all your contributions to Ortiz
robotics sure we're going to need that
watch back I don't even know where you
got one of those oh this this was a gift
from Cal pretty sure this belongs to
me spend the minimal amount to get this
prototype shipped I'm working on a
ballistic simulation to test the
accuracy and effectiveness of the
warhounds simulation yes since we can't
test these prototypes in the open we
have created an augmented reality
simulation complete with real time data
on the effects of your gear and Tech on
hostile elements and who are these
hostile elements operators who we trust
and have volunteered to be digital
cannon fodder for your warhounds as a
training
exercise the suits we have designed will
track all their Biometrics and the data
We Gather from them will be invaluable
did Cal put you up to
this we can't afford this put it on soov
Tab she's got the money for it you can't
keep putting cow's R&D on the Black Tusk
budget why not well this isn't for her
Tech she doesn't want the AI she doesn't
want Isaac she doesn't want untested
Tech either are you going to give
operators warhound of course not but I
am going to let them know what it feels
like to fight one you're going to make
the black tus Tech part of the field
test yes we will field test her Tech and
gear as the AI generated hostile force
and get realtime assessment of how the
operator reacts that testing is for
Black Tusk and goes on their
budget we can't test the system in the
open so we need to come up with a way to
simulate battle conditions what kind of
simulation one that is as realistic as
possible for our operators you mean like
a VR simulation no augmented reality but
more realistic well that should be easy
enough with the contact lens yes but I
want them to feel the hits
if it's just the visual we won't be able
to assess the real stress and pressure
on the body they are talking about
giving Isaac to gym teachers in Mula I
want to know how they would react in a
real Combat situation you want them to
feel pain yes people in pain will react
in unpredictable and dangerous ways I
want to know what these Ops will do when
they are really in pain and Afraid
before I give them live
rounds
how's the testing going impressive and
horrifying care to expand on that
analysis well I went to a play last
night and every member of the theater's
phones are now in the database giving
continuous wiretaps and uploading their
text and voicemail histories along with
online searches and social media
profiles so a success if you think
waiting through millions of hours of new
data is a success sure it doesn't filter
oh it filters but it's arbitrary and it
only tells you what it thinks is
relevant what's the problem well there
was a college student at the play last
night she has a crush on her professor
was talking about how she was going to
have a one-on-one with him today and was
going to try and seduce him any red
flags on the professor a just some Eagle
maniacal adjunct at Cooper Union what
does he teach science theology has been
doing lectures about climate change
human interference and how if we aren't
careful viruses will evolve to solve the
problems for us sounds like a c is he
dangerous everyone is dangerous but this
is just invasive we aren't tracking him
we're tracking a student well sometimes
we need non-criminal informants let me
know how the meeting goes I don't want
to listen to a young girl seduce her
professor if she succeeds we can send an
anonymous tip to the College
administration I didn't join the NSA to
tattle on dirty old men to the
admissions board we save the lives in
front of us you can get a predator off
the streets it's not as glamorous as
taken down an international cartel but
it's still the job do the job
sir we need to talk about Gordon Amherst
did he finally sleep with his student or
did he build a biological weapon the
world has never seen before he did not
sleep with a student and I can't confirm
whether or not he is working on a
biological weapon you can't confirm
biological weapon that's correct sir is
he working on a biological weapon I
cannot confirm that sir so he's not
working on a biological weapon and is
just a c I cannot confirm that sir has
anyone ever told you you can be really
annoying and obtuse yes sir that's why
I'm an analyst and not a field operative
sir okay so you're obsessed with Gordon
Amherst and believe he may be a threat
to National Security but can't prove
that and all you have to go on is some
rants about climate change and his
association with Vali chenko Vitali what
now chenko Russian vist who specializes
in 3D printing my nephew is into 3D
printing why do we care about grown men
who make plastic Miniatures we don't but
we should care about grown men who can
manufacture
viruses trig I need a favor anything for
my favorite Evil Genius I'm not evil
just a genius what do you expect from a
trapezoid God I love your sense of humor
what do you need need you to do a field
test on those new warhounds for nap
already did
aside from the creepy biped action
they're working great I want you to run
the test again with Anna you know Nat
doesn't want the AI she wants the
guidance system how does she expect the
warhounds guidance system to operate
independently without an AI fine but if
she hates it you can remove Anna right
she's not just going to slip in there
and corrupt or rewrite the code or
anything like that right of course not
she's just here to collect data she's
not a person she's not even a shape just
a series of ones and zeros don't be
paranoid it's not like she could augment
reality and murder The
Operators sir we need to abandon the
site what site the Detention Center
what's happening confirmed contamination
what kind of contamination Chimera not
the [__] in New York affirmative how the
hell did he get here asymptomatic
carrier she was in New York before being
arrested at the mall one of the
protesters
I knew we shouldn't have let dcpd use
our Detention Center no this was one of
ours Eco terrorists was arrested trying
to light a Christmas tree on fire we
stopped that attack in New York before
all of this happened the same group
tried again in DC a week later Isaac
intercepted their comms at least that's
working we need more space we need to
quarantine the staff from the detention
center and move our operations from the
data center it's too risky to stay here
long term report to the testing facility
we'll set up a quarantine I'll let the
teams know give me a date need to get it
all set up in the meantime isolate and
see if we can find a way to Rapid test
for infected we don't need a rapid test
since why Isaac can detect viral loads
well that's not terrifying infected need
to be separated we don't know what the
recovery rate is infected doesn't mean
dying and we can study the asymptomatic
carriers maybe use their blood to find
the vaccine we could get ahead of this
thing you're a biologist now no but
Amherst is the college professor yeah
the not a viable threat he made this if
we can get into his apartment or office
we might be able to reverse engineer
this [__] he created sorry sir I
didn't mean to swear I'm just very tired
it's fine well we all are get everyone
packed and ready and bring whatever you
need to the facility to continue working
on containing this thing thank you
sir okay Cal your boys are outfitted in
a latest tech this is a state-of-the-art
simulation using augmented reality to
provide your operators a realistic
combat experience without having to
leave the comfort and safety of the
facility and protecting your investment
from prying eyes you don't have to sell
me on the pitch I already agreed to the
test agents are you ready Alpha Ready
sir Bravo ready good to see you again
Alex Vivian okay let's get this test of
yours underway your objective is to
utilize the mobile shade server to
access Intel and utilize your shade Tech
to infiltrate the bunker copy that this
is going to be fun oh look you did use
my fire turret after all only for the
simulation they are not suitable for the
field Viv good to know it wasn't
completely wasted work and hey nice to
confirm you can actually follow design
directions nicely done
Alex